oh you guys you guys so I ran a poll I
ran a poll on one of my videos in
regards to whether hazel should continue
on with 2d or 3d development what kind
of stuff are you guys interested in
there you interested in 2d rendering in
3d rendering should we have beautiful 3d
scenes should we have blazing fast 2d
rendering it's all just so amazing which
one do you want and based on that poll
that I ran in that video two-thirds of
you write like 66 67 percent don't
remember two-thirds of you said I want
3d comments were like you know man just
bring on the 3d that's what we care
about I was so sure that it was gonna be
3d that I already started planning 3d
you know I saw PBR like image based
lighting just animation all this kind of
complex stuff not easy to teach at all
but no Jenna I started planning that for
you guys because that's the way it's
gonna be
everyone wants 3d and then and then I
was like you know what I hate this kind
of YouTube pulse stuff that's in like
some video that's weird or I can't even
see how many people have voted why don't
I run an actual poll like on the YouTube
community kind of page thing I'll just
make a post will be a poll and I'll ask
you guys one more time this will be the
final definitive poll 2d or 3d you
jerkers you clowns right 50% 50% on each
yeah I'm watching the boats come in 1000
votes two thousand votes three thousand
votes 5050 so festival that just tells
me that you guys have absolutely no idea
or you actually want write her like 50
percent that doesn't happen
it's like saying like here's a line you
know pick a side guys and you just half
of you literally go on one side half you
go on the other side like when does that
ever happen ridiculous right and finally
crosses over like tips are like 4,000
votes it's coming time for me to decide
I'm thinking at that point is like 50/50
maybe I should start doing like two
episodes awake one of each or something
cuz clearly half my audience wants
something completely different than the
other half 4,000 votes 4,000 votes tips
over
1% where does 51% go to 2d yeah
2d now me personally I probably would
have picked 2d to do first
right because 2d is something that has
an end right 2d rendering is kinda like
you know yeah you start it you end it
you kind of done that that's as far as
2d rendering goes 3d rendering we're
still trying to work out how to do that
the industry is still trying to work out
what the best way to render stuff in 3d
actually is still kind of just very much
being figured out and people are
learning trying new techniques that's
never gonna an tree rendering and hazel
could continue doing that for years and
years and years that's kind of where all
the advancements are coming from you
don't hear about some massively awesome
solution that someone's created for tewi
rendering no because that's kind of like
I mean quote unquote solved but sure you
can make it faster you can maybe render
more on the screen with you know if you
optimize it well and do whatever but
mostly that's kind of solved right so 2d
rendering is great but then you guys had
me so convinced that you want a 3d guys
went ahead planned all this stuff it's
been all this time I don't have to throw
all that away because it looks like
we're gonna be doing 2d and it's not
even like it won by a long shot right
I'm gonna get dis slice I'm gonna get
people being like probably half of you
being like I wanted 3d wedding three why
is chotto so stupid he doesn't know that
3d is the way to go you know right
enough I don't and quit this YouTube
thing you just watch me yeah guys I'm
just kidding trudy is the way that we're
gonna do it and that's totally fine by
me in fact that's probably what I would
have picked if you gave me a choice just
because of as I mentioned earlier it
kind of has an end
yeah been sitting here planning what I'm
gonna do with 2d it's looking pretty
good to be honest I'm gonna try and
actually make 2d very interesting for
you guys because I know that not
everyone's gonna be interested in this
and that's totally fine
in fact the good news is that if you
don't care about 2d if you just want to
jump into 3d and kind of jump into the
fancy graphics physically based
rendering that kind of stuff I've
already done that in the Hayslip
development branch a couple days ago I
put up a video I'll link it up there of
me trying to fix a problem in the hazel
development branch go ahead and check
that video out if you haven't already it
shows off a bunch of 3d stuff that I've
already written in the hazel development
branch and of course you can get access
to that hazel development project right
now if you just go to
patreon.com/scishow
the Cherno and help support this channel
can hazel and everything that
here on YouTube so because of that is
cooler there's kind of something for
everyone we're gonna just publicly here
on YouTube move on to doing 2d stuff for
hazel we're going to take hazel down the
2d development route which i think is
really exciting because it means that we
can kind of get hazel to the point where
we can actually start making games with
hazel which is kind of you know most of
the point of having a game engine and on
the other side of things for those who
are interested in the 3d development of
hazel you can follow along with those
videos that I'll kind of release
periodically or just get access to
everything by helping to support this
channel alright so Trudy
how are we going to do this 2d is not an
easy task it's not necessarily a very
hard task but it's also not easy and I
think that to do it well as well it
requires requires a little bit of
thought so the way that we're kind of
kind of gonna tackle this is I want to
make this as fine as possible for
everyone we could run a tree sprites we
could just make something very basic
like a 2d platformer I'm just gonna
going by kind of all in I want to see
like a million particles on the screen
or something just to knee like sprites
behaving in some kind of fashion I want
to just go all in I want to make
something that visually looks impressive
I want to add post-processing to a post
effect stuff like that so we can have
blooms so that we can have like you know
blurring and just cool stuff like that
color grading you know I want to kind of
push this kind of 2d rendering and make
it as high quality as we possibly can
other stuff that we'll have to tackle as
a result of this are things like font
rendering which I honestly wanted to
kind of just shove under the rug for a
while because I definitely don't like
doing that um and then we might have to
talk about like UI and a UI system and
layouts and stuff like that which I'm
also not the biggest fan of we'll have
2d animation this is just some of the
things that I've kind of written but
overall I think it should be pretty
exciting now what I want to do to make
this a little bit more interesting
because game engine series videos only
come out once a week and they take they
take quite a while for me to make just
because of course I want to get my
explanations down pretty well in fact
the last video which was about textures
definitely check it out if you haven't
already in the game engine series that
one that goes for like 51 minutes that
video right so that's what I'm talking
about it they're kind of long they're
kind of me trying to obviously not just
show
me adding code but also kind of I guess
teach and explain how to do what I'm
doing why I'm doing what I'm doing the
reasons behind certain decisions how
things work that kind of stuff and
because of that they can kind of go on
for a while so while I make those videos
and in fact laiá laiá kind of research
and implement hazel 2d just in my own
spare time on my own kind of local copy
of the hazel code what I want to do is
maybe start bringing up some kind of dev
vlog videos and these dev vlog videos
will just kind of show my day or the
last couple days what I've kind of
achieved anything that I've actually
like got to show for myself I might just
show like on a screen capture or
something like that and I'm gonna just
work it in and just kind of discuss I
guess what I'm thinking about while I'm
planning you know this 2d system for
hazel think that'll be really cool for
you guys to see in addition to the game
engine series also just kind of like
vlog style videos in which I kind of
just discuss how everything is gonna
work and just show what I've basically
done so let me know what you think of
that idea hopefully you guys will like
it I'm just gonna try and put as much
production quality into these videos can
I make some really beautiful shots and
I'm honestly just really looking forward
to getting Trudy hazel up and running
and that's how I kind of got this idea
you know I was like literally like
yesterday I was like I'm gonna have to
sit down at my desk and do all of this
work but since I'm just you know working
like from home now since I'm a
professional youtuber and I'm working on
hazel I'm doing all this stuff this is
normally around right like to talk to
about this kind of stuff so why don't
make videos and why not kind of just
start recording my process and just show
you guys how I go about you know
researching and implementing something
like 2d rendering and 2d game engine
support into hazel so anyway let me know
what you guys think in the comments
section below I just want to kind of
make a quick update video just sharing
what we're gonna do with hazel which of
course is 2d and also just letting you
know some of the ideas that I had for
videos in the future I will see you next
time good bye strong
[Music]
[Music]